for president Trump notching a partial
legal win during a preliminary hearing
for his trial on alleged interference
with the 2020 election a federal judge
refusing to issue a blanket order that
would restrict the former president from
talking about new evidence she is
instead imposing a more limited order
that bars publicly discussing material
deemed sensitive by the government Trump
railing against the case earlier this
week saying it infringes on his first
amendment rights
the cases is a ridiculous case it's a
First Amendment case but we don't want
Trump to speak so they want me they take
away your rights on First Amendment now
they sue because so now I have one of
these lunatic reporters back there
saying sir would like to talk to you
about your case or I'm sorry I'm not
allowed to talk about it somehow that's
not good for votes do you agree when we
say I can't talk I'd love to I will talk
about it I will they're not taking away
my first amendment
judge to you on the First Amendment
question and the judge here siding
mostly with the president but I think it
says a lot that the prosecution was
trying to get him to essentially have a
gag order never underestimate the feds
they are notorious for this look this is
a trial about Free Speech it's often
running with a Prohibition against free
speech and that's the irony of all of
this I understand that what the judge is
doing I do and in the article 8 of the
protective order it basically a
paragraph eight it basically says that
there's certain information like uh
personally identifying Witnesses their
addresses that makes sense that needs to
be a prohibited rule six materials grand
jury materials grand jury testimony I
don't have a problem with that uh but
then what they do is order by the
government's filter team I'm not going
to get in the weeds here but they say
that there are certain evidence that
will be produced at trial is sensitive
and Donald Trump cannot talk about it
well wait a minute you're going to
produce as evidence at a public trial in
front of a jury why can't he talk about
it what are you worried about you're
worried about your case you're worried
about the public hearing the other side
maybe and other than a courtroom setting
but the best part of it is where the
judge is putting a an obligation on the
part of Defense counsel to not allow
Donald Trump to take notes from the
information that he gets from the
government and Council must inspect any
other notes he takes to make sure that
the defendant AKA Donald Trump hasn't
copied down personal information I mean
this this is ridiculous Lawrence not
underestimating the feds they don't want
not just Donald Trump talking they also
didn't want Twitter talking when they
got into president Trump's Twitter
account they're saying we're subpoena on
this information and anybody at Twitter
should not tell the Target that this is
happening which seems to be
problematic yeah they also thought that
he was a flight risk as well right even
though he has 24-hour Secret Service
um I I hope the court understands that
Donald Trump is almost baiting them to
arrest him he wants to get locked up he
wants that to be the rallying cry for
his supporters to say look they've been
after me the entire time I've been
telling you this since day one and by
extension they're after you so he's
baiting the court to see how far they
want to go he already thinks that it's a
sham prosecution many his supporters
think the same thing if you want to see
Donald Trump reelected throw him in jail
that will be his campaign rallying cry
so I I just would encourage the court
since they decided to make this a
political process and not a legal
process to be careful because we already
know she doesn't like Trump yeah if you
want to see him get reelected hold him
in contempt of court so Jessica how many
t-shirts do you think the Trump campaign
will sell of a trump mug shot should
that happen some point well he will be
getting a mug shot in Atlanta
um that will be the only one of his
indictments they said that he'll
actually be photographed yes I'm sure
that the swag will be fierce that's
coming from all of this but I don't
think he wants to get put in jail the
man doesn't even like sleeping in a
hotel let alone in a jail cell so I I
think that he is
genuinely and obviously you know we're
not pals we don't chat about it but
I think that when you look at what he's
facing with the four indictments and
putting aside the the New York
indictment which I think is on a
different kind of level than the other
ones
um there's real concern when you have
this many counts that you're facing that
you're going to get convicted of
something and I think that that's scary
for anyone let alone someone who has had
a tremendously privileged and lovely
life in terms of how they live this idea
that you're going to be going to prison
um I think that it was a good thing that
this judge mostly sided with the Trump
Council just to put it out there that
she's not in anyone's bag here that she
can read the order and say this is going
too far but I do feel this way she was
very clear again it's not about a First
Amendment that Donald Trump is not a
normal citizen anymore he's a defendant
and there are restrictions he's out on
defendants but he's out on bail he can't
uh do any witness tampering and she did
also say that the trial will be sped up
right if he goes out and talks about it
because the jury pool what about that
trial date Brian uh January 2nd 2024
which of course is right before the
primary relationship New Year's Eve
getting ready yeah no I just love it the
experts like uh the judge says in normal
cases like this takes two to three years
to get ready and he wants to get ready
in six months what does Jack Smith care
why do you care Jack Smith why don't you
just do a good job Prosecuting and try
to get Justice are you concerned about
the election the judge says this I
cannot and will not factor into my
decision the effect it will have on the
campaign or either side okay you're not
going to factor it in but Jack Smith's
certainly going to factor it in and do
you really think that she's going to
wait two to three years to let this
happen I'm going to amend what you said
I do think that he is daring to put in
jail but I don't think there's any way
he does so Chris Christie will heard Ron
DeSantis us can call out the president
who's competing with him for the
nomination and Joe Biden if he chooses
call out the president specifically for
what they feel he did wrong in these
cases and Trump's going to go I wish I
could come back I just don't think I can
come back at this I don't want to get
myself in trouble
11.6 million pages of documents has been
handed over 2 300 boxes what are the
chances that Donald Trump is not going
to say something that this judge is fine
sensitive if you want to divide this
country like ever before you take the
leading nominee on the right and you
throw him in jail leading up to a trial
that someday somehow will stop will
start before the election that will
divide this country like something we
haven't seen it doesn't matter though if
people are going to the polls right to
elect the next free leader of the Free
World that you know if it's somebody who
committed crimes like a conspiracy to
defraud the United States with the
laptop
story for 24 hours from the New York
Post how can you
gotta run but the bottom line is that
Donald Trump is allowed to talk about it
and he's not the kind of person who
holds back so I'm sure Brian will hear
lots about the case from him directly
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else